listen if that gives us a nicely
definition for a radian underneath your
final you might need to put this on the
next page right one Radian is so here's
our definition okay it's a bit of a
weird definition to start with which is
why I didn't start with it I wanted to
give you this geometric sense but this
worded definition is really important
one Radian is the size of the angle that
forms an arc you can see all of these
curved parts here apart from this one
which is the entire circumference you
call this an arc semi circle you'd call
this an arc a quarter of a circle and
you'd call this an arc which is one unit
along one Radian is the size of the
angle that forms an arc and this is the
really nice part of it that forms an arc
equal to the radius of the circle that's
what a Radian is a Radian is however far
you need to turn so that the arc you
make is the same it matches the radius
of the circle that you're in what's
really nice about this is we didn't have
to actually do unit circles to
demonstrate this we could have picked
circles of any size which is why in fact
you didn't draw circles of any size if
you take if you like measured across
what your radius is right and then you
measure around that arc those two
distances should match that's what makes
a Radian a Radian so if you had a circle
twice the size of a circle the radius of
two then how big would that arc be if
you had a Radian there it'll be two it
would be exactly the same it'd be double
because I had a circle that's double
size okay now this is the big idea we're
introducing this new way of measuring
angles number one sorry self-evidently
so that we can work with circles a
little more easily every other time
you've had to work with circles you had
to do some conversion it always involved
pi okay but now we're trying to take
that out of the equation by using a
different unit okay for now we want to
be able to translate for
into the other which is why I asked you
to write this if you haven't written it
already
I suggest you write this particular line
down and put a nice big box around it
okay because what allows you to do is
it's sort of like enough is anyone um
does anyone heard of the rosetta stone
do you did you learn about that
the rosetta stone was someone's gonna
help me out here there was like Egyptian
hieroglyphics I think there was
Phoenicians and a third one I can't
remember some other ancient language and
the whole idea was WOW
we couldn't read these three languages
but now I've got the same thing written
in all three and now we can convert
between them it was like a a really
Keystone moment part of the pun before I
thank you for being able to work between
these languages this piece here is kind
of like the Rosetta Stone of Radiance
right if you remember that one hundred
to one hundred eighty degrees is pi
radians you can convert back and forth
for example if this is what one Radian
is how would I work out the size of say
three radians three radians what I would
do is I'd say okay if that's one Radian
I just multiply that by three and that
will give me the number of degrees three
multiplied by a hundred and eighty on pi
that'll be the number of degrees can you
just punch that into your calculator for
me three and then multiply it by a
hundred eighty or PI what should you get
three radians 170 171 think about that
for a second think about the diagrams
you already have on your page does that
intuitively make sense three radians is
just a little bit less than PI radians
you see that yeah
bingo so if I said instead of three
radians
I wanted eight radians I'd say well
eight times a hundred eighty-one pi okay
if I wanted to go in the other direction
which is actually going to be a bit more
common for us right now cuz we're good
at degrees right if I said to you we've
done some nice convenience 360 180 90
what's another common angle that you
deal with all the time in degrees a
common angle using 45 to shop this will
do 45 degrees if I wanted to turn this
into radians right what I would say is
take that 45 and instead of multiplying
by 180 on pi because that takes you from
raised to degrees I want to go in the
reverse direction I'm gonna multiply by
the reciprocal pi on 180 instead of 180
on pi now you could put that to your
calculator okay
but the problem is your calculator is
going to take PI it's gonna turn into
decimals right you don't need to have a
look have a look
45 180 can we like simplify this can we
write an equivalent fraction it's nicer
Anita how many 45 can you fit into 180
keep it for them right so if I go kids
or kids all I get PI on 4 radians which
should make sense because it's half of
this do you see that give me another
angle another common a goal that you get
30 30 I could say 30 and I'm going to
multiply by PI on 180 that'll convert me
into I shoulda said radiance over here
so I could write PI on 180 radians but
you can probably see that's easy to
cancel right you'll get PI on 6 very
good just as familiar as 30 degrees is
you're going to start saying on peyote 6
I can recognize that that's 30 degrees
if I said to you I think I heard another
like to 70 was it 270 degrees if you
have a look at what you've got here do
we need to do the calculation these
nicely numbers we should be able to work
it out
270 is not half it's like it's
three-quarters the way around right that
would give me 270 think about it
3/4 way around we know that this is pi
we know this is
Pilon - so if that's 270 degrees how
many radius do you get if you add these
two together PI and PI on two you get
one and a half lots of Pi or more
commonly we would say is through PI on -
right
so this is how you're going to convert
from radians to degrees this is how
you're going to convert from degrees to
radians